- [Jason] Ndamukong Suh
has been one of the most
feared defenders in the NFL
since the moment he came into the League.
- [Suh] When I'm on the football field,
I'm in between those white lines,
my job is to piss everybody off.
And so if I don't do that,
I'm not doing my job.
- [Jason] At 6'4" and
more than 300 pounds,
Ndamukong Suh has done his job
in the NFL for 12 years now,
sometimes, maybe too well.
- [Rodgers] He got, you know, frozen feet
and didn't realize he
was stepping on my calf,
he also stomped on one of
my teammates at one point.
He's been, you know, in my time,
one of the most dominant
three techniques in the game.
- [Suh] And I understand not
everybody's gonna like me
and that's okay.
But I guarantee the
people that don't like me
don't know who I am,
and haven't even taken the
time to get to know me.
- [Jason] After spending
a few days with Ndamukong
here in the rainy city of Portland,
I've gotten an insight
into a soft-spoken native Portlandian,
family man restaurateur
and real estate investor,
who's endeavoring to have more
impact with his businesses
than he's had against
quarterbacks in the NFL.
- It's a simple concept of like,
I don't wanna be at the top of the pyramid
or be amongst the 1%
and be there by myself.
I wanna bring other people
with me that are like-minded
and you wanna work with them.
And when you have the
opportunity to help other people
at the same time, it's a
smart business decision.
Why not create both?
Dunk.
- [Katya] Say hello.
Should we get the basketball
court and basketball-
- King's is more the observer
and analyzes before he dives in,
and Khari is full throttle
right into it, right away.
They don't go anywhere without each other.
The few times that they have,
they're trying to figure
out where the other one is.
And I have twin sisters
and I have twin cousins.
Twins definitely run in the family,
she has twins on her side too.
- [Jason] For someone who is
so single-minded on the field,
seeing Suh in his native
habitat, it's a bit startling,
and not just because he's a dad.
From his home office,
bouncing from Zooms to calls to text,
he's methodically creating an empire.
It includes investments in tech companies
like Quip and Ember,
and hospitality investments
including restaurants
in Portland and beyond.
But the primary focus for
Suh has been real estate.
Over the past decade,
much of his investments
have been focused on multifamily
and commercial projects.
So tell me your business
philosophy, like in a nutshell,
like how do you distill it down?
- Just understanding that investing
and social impact can go,
without question, hand in hand.
And I think you can impact other
people's lives and do good,
but at the same time,
make smart business
decisions where it's...
I've always seen it as a true
give and take relationship
versus just someone always taking,
and I think that's where
that capitalistic mindset
that majority of America lives in.
It's a short trip from where we're sitting
to see where Suh came from.
His home in the off season
is here in the Irvington
district of Portland.
And his house is only a few streets away
from where he grew up.
- This hoop's been here for ages.
- [Jason] Oh my gosh.
And the family that owned this house,
their son actually played in the NBA.
There used to be at the far end,
we called that little hoop
where we'd have our main dunk contest.
- What was Portland like,
like when you were growing up?
I mean now it's seen as
this like boom town, right?
But was it like that 20 years ago?
- [Suh] No, Portland was very, very small.
Everybody knew everybody pretty much.
- Yeah.
Growing up in Portland, Suh
was surrounded by sports.
Nike's headquarters was
just 20 minutes away
and he still works out
there when he's home.
His older sister, Ngum Suh,
also became an elite athlete.
She'd end up going to the 2004
Olympics as a soccer player,
playing for their father's
home country of Cameroon.
Oftentimes in a family,
especially when you have
multiple superstars,
it's clear that like this
family's in the business
of growing superstar athletes.
- My parents could care less about that.
They wanted us to be in athletics
and have that fulfillment
of being in sports.
But hands down, education
was the number one.
And my sister's super smart,
she got her degree in kinesiology
and biological sciences.
- [Jason] Suh's parents
divorced when he was two,
but stayed close.
His mom was an elementary school teacher
and his dad owned an HVAC company.
- As a young kid, I enjoyed
going to work with him.
I got to spend a lot of time
with my dad on job sites.
And it's really what got
me into the business.
As I got a little bit older
towards middle school,
it would be me going to the
job site and being able to say,
"Alright, you can earn 5, 10
dollars towards your bike."
He just wanted to see
if I'd be willing to get up
at six o'clock in the morning.
- Right.
- [Suh] This was my dad's house
that where you grew up in.
Where he bought the building,
lived on one side and
rented the other side.
And that's where we
really started to learn
about real estate
or how I started to
learn about real estate.
- [Jason] From those early days.
Suh's fascination with and
ambition in real estate
only grew, especially
as a pro football career
gave him the means to eye
bigger and bigger projects.
He's been buying and building property
in his hometown of Portland
as well as across the United States,
including luxury residential,
office and hospitality space,
and affordable housing,
all with the mission to help
build generational wealth
through real estate.
And real estate is one of the
most tried and true places
to store and grow wealth.
Buying and owning property,
commercial or residential,
when done right,
can be a source of income as
well as accrue value over time.
That's if you choose projects
wisely and have patience.
Over the past few years,
the pandemic both increased demand
and lowered the supply of housing
leading to skyrocketing values.
At the same time,
low interest rates made
acquiring the capital
needed to purchase properties even easier.
More recently though,
rising mortgage rates and new supply
have begun to change that picture
and rents have been
increasing at historic levels.
Owning real estate has
the additional benefit
of influencing, maybe even transforming,
the neighborhood and the
community around you.
That's an idea passed down
to Suh from his father.
- Hey.
- He assembled a handful of
different lots and projects,
and this is one of them that has been,
I won't say a unicorn, but has
been very, very profitable.
If you look at the building,
you had the exterior.
So we gutted everything inside
and kept the exterior facade
and then built on top of that.
It was originally a chop
shop when we first took over.
People at night,
when I was growing up in
the 90s and early 2000s
would not walk up and down
these streets by any means.
And you see it's live,
you got great restaurants up and down,
coffee shops further down.
You got, everybody probably
knows the Salt & Straw,
they're right up the street.
- Right.
- There's no way they would
be here back in the 90s.
So my dad had a great vision in focus
for seeing where the city was moving.
- [Jason] Athletes investing
in real estate properties
in order to renovate them isn't
that remarkable at its face.
What separates Suh is his fluency
in the details of the business.
He learned that on the job with his dad
as well as in the classroom.
- [Sports Narrator] Account for him,
plan for him, recognize him,
as perhaps the most
disruptive defensive player
in college football.
- He's the most dominant player
that I've seen this season.
- [Jason] A heavily recruited athlete,
he opted for the University of Nebraska,
which has not only a great football team,
but a highly regarded
construction engineering program.
- I knew leaving high school,
I wanted to get an engineering degree.
And because my ultimate goal
was to come back here to Portland
and build another division
to my dad's company.
Granted that didn't necessarily happen
because other things transpired, but like-
- Like going pro.
- Yeah, like going pro, yeah.
I think I get it from both my
parents, but primarily my dad.
We've always been somewhat
calculated and focused
on what we wanna accomplish in building
and connecting with the right people.
And then also just learning from others.
- Lincoln, Nebraska may
not be the first place
you'd think to meet
some of the world's most
influential business people.
The Portland Metro area alone
has more people living in it
than the entire state of Nebraska.
But his play on the
field allowed him to meet
and maintain relationships
with future mentors
in his business career,
including the Oracle of Omaha
himself, Warren Buffett.
- I loved the Wall Street
Journal story last year
that called you a secret finance nerd.
Let's talk a little
bit about that because-
- This guy is smart, believe me.
- You're not somebody-
- [Suh] Ever since then,
we've been close friends,
confidant, and really a true mentor,
being able to bounce a bunch
of different ideas off,
and then also understand
how he envisions the world.
Although he's not fully into real estate
and he's changed a little bit
'cause he now has Berkshire
Hathaway Homes and whatnot.
- I'm gonna end this.
- [Commentator] Down goes Suh.
- [Suh] That long term vision
in that being able to buy and hold
is one of the greatest things
ever that I learned from him.
- [Jason] Suh also met
with one of the most interesting people
who has split time between the locker room
and the boardroom, Joe Moglia.
Moglia's career began
in the coaching world,
but he would rise through the
ranks to lead TD Ameritrade
as CEO from 2001 to 2008,
and chairman from 2008 to 2020,
navigating the company through
the global financial crisis
and its aftermath,
as well as its eventual
combination with Schwab.
- He was around my entire senior year
and one day I just asked him, he's like,
"You always leave every
Friday before our games
and come back Saturdays, ready to go.
Like where do you go?"
And it's always like
a black car going out.
He's like, "I go to New York,
I go take care of business
with TD Ameritrade,
I'm the chairman there,
and then I come back and obviously
have my role here with you guys."
And I was like, wow,
that's pretty interesting.
Like I'd love to learn more.
And so he said,
"Well, make sure you follow
up with me after the season."
- Alright so I asked him
this exact same question,
check out what Joe had to say.
- So our first step, our
first step is going to be,
I want you to come down to my office.
The season was over
and I wanna see the budget
that you would put together.
So he comes down, it's
about a month later,
and I gotta tell you, I was impressed.
He comes into my office
with a suit on, tie on.
He looked great.
And we sat down, he showed me his budget.
The budget was about $60,000.
Now we've talked about that a little bit.
In two or three months,
he was gonna get a pretty
significant contract
and he was gonna make a shitload of money,
and a $60,000 budget
with regards to all the different things
that the people's gonna
be interacting with
is probably not gonna quite work out.
- Yeah, that's exactly right.
He's like, "Man, you're gonna be spending
anywhere from 20, 30,000 dollars a month."
And I was like there's no
way, I'm in college right now.
My rent's like 1,500.
Yeah, I didn't imagine ever getting there.
Lo and behold, I'm there so.
- [Jason] There was of course
one other pivotal person
he'd meet and cultivate
a relationship with
during his college days,
his future wife, Katya.
- I have only been a champion
with this beautiful lady in my life.
- [Katya] We met all the way back in 2009.
I was a women's basketball player
and he was a football player.
And the best way that
I like to explain it is
he ran after me a lot,
and would always try to kinda
say he's gonna break my ankles
or when are we gonna play one-on-one?
And I was like, "Hi, who are you?"
And so after some time I
finally gave him a little,
a little chance and I got to know him,
and truly he became my best friend.
- [Jason] The two have had
a whirlwind past few years.
They moved in together in 2018,
were engaged in 2019,
and had their then traditional
Zoom wedding back in 2020.
In February of 2021, Ndamukong would win
his first Super Bowl with
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers,
and just a few months later,
the two would welcome their
twin sons, Khari and Kingston.
When the two aren't changing diapers
or doing the latest TikTok trend,
they're business partners,
working together out
of the same home office
for much of the off season.
- We really both listen
to each other's calls.
We kind of have what's
going on in the mornings
after workouts and when the
boys are doing breakfast,
we'll be like, "Okay,
what's your plan for today?
How many calls do you have?
When are your calls?
Are there ones that I can listen in on?
Are there ones that he's
like, you know what,
I wanna, I wanna be a part of that,
I wanna participate or just listen in."
- [Jason] The two also work together
on the Suh Family Foundation,
the charitable arm of
Suh's business ventures
that focuses on empowering
people with resources
for long term success.
One issue they're working to
address is financial literacy.
- Right now, there is no
financial literacy requirement
at all at any level.
And to me that's mind blowing.
It, finances are in our life
from the minute we are born
to the minute we are no longer here.
And so to not have a
requirement of how things run,
how to properly use your finances,
is in, is to me quite insane.
We have specific programs that
we work with that students
that are coming from all
different types of backgrounds
are able to come together
and really learn.
How that's structured, right now,
we're focused on our own backyard,
which would be Portland, Oregon.
The ultimate goal would
be to be in every state.
- [Jason] And while many athletes
give back to their community,
The Suh's extend that notion
to all of their business
enterprises as well,
looking not only at how they
can impact the bottom line,
but impact their communities.
And one of those spaces
has been restaurants.
- Hi.
- [Jason] One of Suh's
restaurant investments
is here in Downtown Portland.
A fast casual restaurant
called Baes Fried Chicken,
he started with a previously successful
Portland-based restaurateur
named Micah Camden.
To understand it, I ordered a
chicken sandwich for myself,
for journalism.
Tell me about where we are.
- We are in Downtown Portland.
This building was built in 1882.
So that's an old building.
You don't get much older
than that in Portland.
We got the fried chicken sandwich,
we got the chicken strips.
It's easy, it's approachable,
it's super great quality.
When we opened this up,
we went straight organic
on all the chicken,
which was awesome.
- It's very, very juicy, so to be careful.
- [Jason] But good food
and a good location
aren't guarantees of success
in the restaurant world.
Restaurants are tricky
businesses for athletes,
seemingly easy to understand,
but complex to conceive,
operate and market.
Actually, they're hard
businesses for anyone,
even food pros.
While Micah himself has
had successful ventures
with restaurants like Boxer Ramen,
Little Big Burger, and Blue Star Donut,
in 2016 he had to shut
down a previous attempt
at a fried chicken restaurant.
- [Micah] Restaurants are high risk.
- [Jason] What's appealing to you
about being in this particular
restaurant business?
- It's one, this is a foodie town,
and they got amazing chefs,
people that enjoy quality,
high quality food,
and kind of giving back to my community
is something that was missing.
And then also you come out
and see during a pandemic,
a lot of people are supporting
people in their endeavors
and seeing the success that they're doing
and wanna support people
that when they're sometimes
in their rough spots
or even when they're at their heights.
- [Jason] The last few years
have been far from the salad days
for the restaurant industry.
The pandemic altered dining,
living and working habits,
and everything from
lockdowns to labor shortages
have plagued the food business.
Baes opened this location
only a few months before
the global pandemic
shut down much of the country,
and George Floyd's
murder led to a reckoning
around racial inequality.
As protests and counter
protests swept the country,
Portland became a focal point.
Images of property
destruction by protestors,
who themselves were often the
victims of violent attacks
by extreme right wing groups,
as well as Portland police,
ricocheted across social media,
giving rise to a flood of
disinformation by opponents
of police reform.
- [Micah] This was ground zero,
right out our front door was ground zero
for the nightly protests
that went on for three or four months.
Thankfully enough, this
community knew that this,
this location was owned by Suh
and then we didn't get stuff
thrown through our windows,
you know, stuff like that.
But the attention that
was brought to Portland
via those protests,
it hit its cause, it hit its nerve,
and it started the conversation
that is still going on today.
- [Jason] Portland has in recent years,
been an almost cartoonish
example of a liberal stronghold.
And while coffee shops and
breweries are a thing here,
the real Portland is a complicated place
in a state of near existential crisis,
facing issues around affordability,
the unhoused and crime.
People of color in Portland
have been historically disenfranchised,
especially when it comes to one
of Suh's biggest businesses,
real estate and development.
Like in many cities across
the US, nearly a century ago,
redlining practices
allowed white neighborhoods
easier access to capital
and excluded black and
immigrant communities,
including Suh's home in
the Northeast of Portland
where Irvington was,
quote, still desirable.
Just a few blocks north, Alberta
was considered hazardous.
And while redlining was
made illegal in the 60s,
its effects are still being felt.
Investment in areas like Alberta,
where Suh and his father bought a property
have helped revitalize neighborhoods,
but it's also led to gentrification,
driving up home prices and
pushing people of color out.
Through his development company, HMS,
Suh is hoping to change
the traditional narrative.
- We are down on Alberta,
further down from where we were at before,
but this is 30th, where we
are creating Alberta Alley,
which is going to be a
nice collection of BIPOC
type of restaurants.
- [Jason] Beyond creating a
space for black, indigenous,
and people of color owners of restaurants,
Suh has also brought in
more black investors,
including another pro football
player with Portland roots
named Brennan Scarlett.
We went to take a look,
but as you might expect,
we had to go inside.
Let's go inside.
- I know, we got our Portland bad weather-
- [Jason] And get out
of this Portland rain.
Right now, Alberta
Alley is still very much
a work in progress,
but the intention is to create a space
for multiple restaurants and eateries
in a communal, well,
alley-type experience.
Currently they're working to
bring a Latino-owned expansion
of Papi's Churros and another
Baes Fried Chicken location
to this space.
You guys are native sons, you know,
sort of putting a different
mark on this city.
Tell me about, you know,
your process of being an
owner and not just a like,
participant, not just a
customer to some extent.
- Yeah, Portland's an interesting place
and has a long history of racism,
of marginalizing certain groups.
Like the house that I grew up in,
on the deed, it says that a black person
couldn't own that house, right.
But my dad, you know,
purchased that house back,
you know, in the 90s.
Right now you think about like
purchasing commercial
properties like this, right,
under black ownership.
And then also, you know, the
cycle of having tenants here
and being intentional
about having tenants here
that are represented,
that may have historically
not been able to have
the opportunity to be represented.
- [Suh] When I grew up here,
it was predominantly a black neighborhood
and a lot of different people
just kind of starting
out their businesses here
that really in the BIPOC space.
And so a lot of gentrification
moved those things out
and brought up new developments
and not really looking for a way
to bring those people back in.
And so this is an interesting
way to fold them back into
having that opportunity of
kind of getting kicked out
and now coming back and
hopefully being successful
and finding ways to
help them be successful.
We have a very altruistic view
when it comes to our real estate endeavors
and have multifamily units
and be able to create them
in mixed use developments.
I think one of the most
things I'm gonna be proud of
as we're getting this journey
and started is our ally project
to attainable living initiative,
where we really want to
have the ability to afford
attainable living for everybody.
And we're starting here in Portland.
- There's never been a
greater need for housing
and yet it's almost impossible
to get housing done and developed.
- [Jason] Suh's partner
at HMS is Joel Anderson,
a third generation
contractor and developer
based in Portland.
And while the two have
developed a portfolio
of everything from high-rise
residential to industrial,
one of the common threads is their vision
of the social impact real estate can have.
- Both Suh and I have been very fortunate
and worked very hard.
Some lucky bounces that that win our way.
And there's a whole bunch of people
that we interact with in our communities
that just didn't have
those same opportunities
and have never had access
to invest in commercial real estate.
- [Jason] While real estate investments
have been a great place to store wealth,
the recent housing market
has left many unable to participate,
especially when it comes
to BIPOC communities.
- And I think one of the
ways that we can do that
with alt cap, as we call it,
is giving them the opportunity
to not only pay rent
and understand those different
pieces and keep it afloat,
but also give them the
opportunity to be a part of it.
And one thing you know about people,
when they have ownership into a building,
they take care of it
that much more better.
- [News Broadcaster] All
of these people are really-
- [Jason] Affordable housing,
which about half of Americans
say their community lacks,
is a hot button issue long
freighted with racism.
Some say they oppose it over
perceived increases in crime,
erosion in the tax base,
and increased traffic.
Suh and Joel believe they can
ultimately flip the script
by better knitting residents
into the community economically
by affording everyone a stake.
- Altruistic capital, alt cap,
it's very intention is to bring people in
that have been excluded.
If we take an accredited investor,
somebody and say,
"Okay, you're gonna invest
a $100,000 in this project."
They go, "Yes."
We go, "But you're only gonna
get credit for 95% of that."
And $5,000 or 5% of your investment
is gonna go to a non-profit
alt cap community reinvestment fund.
And we say to them now,
"Okay, you can participate
from 500 to $5,000,
and for every dollar you invest,
we will match you through
the alt cap reinvestment fund
dollar for dollar."
And so if you have
somebody who invests $500,
they now have a thousand
dollars investment
into this project.
They've effectively doubled their return.
- [Jason] It may seem complicated,
but Joel and Suh believe
that programs like alt cap
can give people who've long
been excluded from real estate,
an attainable investment option.
While some investors might balk
at giving up some of their economics,
proponents of this shared ownership
believe it's long overdue.
- If we can get real estate transactions
to include everybody,
you're talking about a
trillion dollar industry
that has the ability to engage
everybody in a micro fashion
earned at a disproportionate rate,
you can transition the wealth
of our country in short order.
- [Jason] Of course, undoing centuries
of economic disparity and
systemic financial bias,
that's a long game.
For Suh, it's his life's work
and he'll be able to
devote even more time to it
once he leaves the game of football.
When you leave the League,
how do you think about
the idea of transition,
especially given everything
that you've already done in business?
- [Suh] Yeah, the transition's
a difficult one for me.
I look at it consistent and
have over the last couple years
from a standpoint,
especially since the
boys came into my life,
I wanna spend as much time with them
and not miss out on things.
- [Jason] How do you
balance like the economics
versus the emotions?
I mean, this is a deep analysis.
This is one of the most
important decisions
you'll ever make.
- [Suh] I think the analysis
is very straightforward.
It comes down to numbers in a lot of ways,
but then also just do I
believe I have more to offer?
Without question.
And do I aspire to be in the hall of fame?
No question.
Do I want to do that at the cost
of not spending time with my kids,
not being around my family?
Timing is always gonna be key to that.
We've got a good process
with me and the wife.
I lean on her a lot and I
think she has a good telltale
to give me some different
things to think about.
And she always says it's
ultimately your decision,
but I truthfully know it's
both of our decisions.